to a guy's point of view he's going to  commit to this girl and what does he get  he doesn't get Purity anymore you know  these These Hoes you know he doesn't he  doesn't get youth anymore so he doesn't  get either of those things a lot of  times she already has a kid so so he  he's not fulfilling his mating strategy  on top of that even if he does find a  good woman that maybe has the qualities  he's looking for she was going to want  him to marry her right and what does he  get out of that oh she can leave and  take half and take my kids and she's  paid to take my kids away from me she  she gets more money if she takes my  children and so from the men's point of  view they're just kind of like eff it  because like women aren't wives nowadays